plus on se rapproche de l'an 2000 et
plus on craint que ce basculement de
date ne rentre fout tous les ordinateurs
de France Lionel Jospin lancera dès cet
après-midi un comité national chargé de
suivre les travaux d'adaptation de tous
les systèmes électroniques du pays une
adaptation qui concerne presque toutes
les entreprises certaines d'entre elles
s'organisent toutes seules d'autres font
appel à une aide extérieure regardez
l'exemple de cette société
d'électromécanique des Alpes maritimes
où se sont rendus Yasmina Farber et
Frédéric Besson donc je voudrais faire
une saisie sur le mois de janvier 19
2000 il me met janvier 92 et il me
marque moi antérieur au premier exercice
d'ici de mois le programme de la
comptabilité sera changé coût de
l'opération 70000 francs et des heures
de travail de saisie mais cette
entreprise qui fabrique des appareils de
contrôle destiné aux chaînes de montage
automobile doit gérer d'autres problèmes
de bug liés à l'an 2000 les clients
veulent être sûrs que leurs outils vont
fonctionner aujourd'hui le problème de
la PME PMI ici c'est de vérifier toutes
les cartes qui sont en circulation chez
les clients depuis les 10 dernières
années et on a des problèmes et ces
problèmes on peut pas forcément les
résoudre par la programmation ce qui est
le cas d'un ordinateur où il suffit de
changer de programme mais c'est le Hard
le matériel qui ne va pas cette PME de
saint-janais gère donc le passage à l'an
2000 en interne mais d'autres
entreprises moins tournées vers
l'informatique ont besoin d'aide les
sociétés de servic établissent des
diagnostics certains professionnels qui
ont anticipé le problème ont renouvelé
leur outil informatique d'autres vont
devoir l'améliorer un investissement qui
ne fait pas plaisir l'an 2000 c'est pas
une fonctionalité supplémentaire ça va
pas aider une entreprise à mieux vendre
ça va aider une entreprise à à subsister
et à exister l'an prochain à pouvoir
faire des facture et autres donc
forcément les directeurs généraux ils
ont quelques réticenceces parce que ça
va coûter sans rapporter directement
mais ceci étant c'est incontournable
dans les Alpes Maritimes une PME sur 5
accuserait du retard l'an 2000 crée des
soucis d'un côté et des emplois dans les
sociétés de services Anice capgéini a
embauché et formé 15 personnes elle
s'occupe exclusivement de ce fameux bug
informatique